ظهرت الآلاف من متغيرات فيروس كورونا
منذ بداية
فيروسات وبائية مثل covet 19 تتغير أو تتغير
باستمرار وبمجرد
دخولها إلى الجسم فإنها تتكاثر وتتطور ، لكن
هذا هو الشيء الوحيد الذي
يغير الفيروس بطريقة يمكن أن
تؤثر علينا سلبًا.  وصف مركز السيطرة على الأمراض
في وقت ما تباينًا
مثيرًا للقلق
تم تحديد omicron لأول مرة باعتباره متغيرًا جديدًا
في نوفمبر بعد موجة من
الحالات في جنوب إفريقيا أدى ظهوره
إلى قيود سفر سريعة في جميع
أنحاء العالم الآن ، وهنا سبب قلق الخبراء على
وجه التحديد بشأن هذا
omicron  يبدو أنه يحمل عددًا كبيرًا من
الطفرات على بروتين سبايك الخاص به ، وهذا
ما يستخدمه الفيروس للاستيلاء على الخلايا
التي يصيبها
أحدها يسمى e484a
ويمكن أن يجعل الفيروس أقل قابلية
للتعرف على بعض الأجسام المضادة التي
تدافع عنا ضد العدوى يمكن أن
تؤثر أيضًا على كيفية إصابة الشخص المصاب.  يستجيب
لعلاجات الأجسام المضادة أحادية النسيلة
، يحمل المتغير أيضًا طفرة
تُعرف باسم
n501y والتي يمكن أن تسبب  من المرجح
أن ينتشر الفيروس عندما يتنفس الناس العطس أو
السعال
، لا يزال الباحثون وصانعو اللقاحات
غير متأكدين مما إذا كانت هذه الطفرات يمكن أن
تؤثر أيضًا على فعالية اللقاح إذا كان البديل
سيكون أكثر قابلية للانتقال أو إذا كان
سيسبب مرضًا أكثر خطورة ،
فإن متغير دلتا الذي تم تحديده لأول مرة
في الهند في أكتوبر 2020.
يمثل الآن 99.9 في المائة من
الحالات في الولايات المتحدة وفقًا
لمركز السيطرة على
الأمراض وهو البديل السائد في
معظم أنحاء العالم مثل omicron delta
يحمل أيضًا طفرة في
بروتين سبايك الخاص به  ثبت أنه يتهرب
من الجهاز المناعي إلى حد ما ، مما
يعني أنه حتى إذا كنت مصابًا من
قبل بمتغير أقدم ، فمن
المحتمل أن تظل مصابًا
بمتغير دلتا ، وكان
متغير ألفا الذي تم تحديده لأول مرة
في سبتمبر 2020
مصدر قلق كبير  قد تتذكر للمسؤولين في هذا الربيع أن
إنجلترا تعرضت لضربة شديدة من قبل
ألفا وسرعان ما انتشرت في جميع أنحاء
العالم
وقد ثبت أنها عابرة.  كانت أكثر قابلية للانتقال بنسبة 50 في المائة
من المتغيرات الأقدم
، كما أنها حملت الكثير من الطفرات
23 منها ،
ولكن في سبتمبر 2021 ، تم
تخفيض رتبتها من متغير مثير للقلق إلى
متغير تتم مراقبته بواسطة cdc
بسبب تأثيره المنخفض على الولايات المتحدة.
شوهد المتغير لأول مرة في جنوب
إفريقيا في وقت مبكر من مايو 2020 ، حيث يحتوي على
طفرة e484k التي يمكن أن تجعل الفيروس
أقل قابلية للتعرف على بعض الأجسام المضادة ، وقد
أظهرت الطفرة n501y التي يُعتقد أنها
تجعل المتغير أكثر عدوى
اختبارات الدم أن متغير بيتا
يمكن أن يصيب الناس  الذين رغبوا في
التطعيم من قبل وكذلك الأشخاص الذين تم تطعيمهم ، لكن
هذا البديل لم يكتسب الكثير من
موطئ قدم في الولايات المتحدة أيضًا
، ومثل ألفا ، فقد تم تحديده الآن على
أنه متغير تتم مراقبته من
قبل cdc ،
هناك الكثير نحن '  ما زلنا نتعلم عن
هذا الفيروس ومتغيراته ، لكن إليك
ما نعرفه يمكن أن يساعد في الحد من انتشار
أقنعة
غسل اليدين الجسدية والمسافة بين
التهوية الجيدة  جميعها لا تزال تعمل ،
وبينما ثبت أن بعض هذه المتغيرات
تتهرب من اللقاحات إلى حد ما ،
تظهر الأبحاث أنه حتى مع
اختراق العدوى ، فإن
الأشخاص الذين تم تطعيمهم ليس من المرجح
أن يمرضوا بفيروس covid19 ، لذلك إذا لم يتم تطعيمك ، فاحصل
على التطعيم
الآن و  تقول CDC إنه يجب على جميع البالغين
أيضًا الحصول على جرعة معززة بعد ستة أشهر
من الجرعة الثانية من لقاح Pfizer moderna
أو بعد شهرين
من جرعة واحدة من جونسون وجونسون